well you may not have noticed that in
fact it seems certain that you did not
notice it but over the weekend a truly
historic moment occurred a movie called
Bros was released by Universal Pictures
Bros is historic because it is gay and I
don't just mean that it has gay actors I
mean in that sense it's like literally
every other Hollywood film and I don't
mean just that it has gay characters
again in that sense it's like every
other Hollywood film Hollywood is very
gay and Hollywood movies have a lot of
gay characters and themes but this movie
is a trailblazer we're told because it's
the first gay romantic comedy to be
produced by a major Hollywood production
company
and in case you're at all confused about
this fact the film's marketing material
especially its trailer makes sure to
beat you over the head with a tire iron
of gayness just so that you don't lose
sight of how historic everything here
really is so here it is watch
hey guys it's Bobby Lieber coming to you
from the future home of the lgbtq plus
Museum everyone is really excited and
totally getting along
this happens to be bisexual awareness
week and no one has acknowledged it
lesbian history month was in March
nobody said a goddamn thing of course
lesbians get a month and we get a week
so what's happening didn't you guys have
an announcement this is a little
unexpected but we are in a throuple
situation you're in a throttle
let me tell you what's Progressive now
being alone I love my life I love my
freedom I love my Independence that's
kind of sad that I don't want to be in a
throuple I don't even want to be in a
couple
[Music]
Bobby I had sex with that 65 year old
Jesus he's ripped I don't know it's like
they injected steroids into Dumbledore
oh my God that's Aaron he's very hot
gay guys are so stupid I know but we've
been smart enough to Brand ourselves as
being smart it's our little secret
[Music]
never mind you saw enough of that you'll
be shocked to hear this but um
that was a flop uh not just a flop but a
full-on fat guy jumping off a diving
board belly flop type of flop uh they
were right you know it turns out the
movie is historic it made history by how
poorly it performed at the box office
it's the gayest comedy of all time and
also the brokest
and there's a Brokeback Mountain joke in
there somewhere but I'm not going to go
there I'll let you make the punch line
despite tons of media hype and a 40
million dollar marketing campaign the
film made less than five million dollars
on its opening weekend uh it generated
that poultry sum on 3350 screens which
is a humiliating average of 1500 bucks
per theater uh the theaters you know
they could have made more money just by
like sending a few employees to
Panhandle in the parking lot just in
abysmal failure but on the bright side I
will admit at least that the comedy did
get a laugh out of me by bombing in such
a hilarious way we must also note that
this film failed so badly in spite of
the Evangelical efforts of the media you
know who sometimes commanded and
sometimes begged us to go see this film
Kevin Fallon The Daily Beast for example
wrote an exhortation a few days ago
headlined
straight people I beg of you go see Bros
in theaters calling us to allyship
Fallon declared that the film is both
historic and quote miraculous and
informed us that it is our duties our
responsibility as straight people to
support it he warned that if the movie
doesn't earn a respectable return we may
never get to see Billy Eichner make out
with a dude on camera again a terrifying
Prospect he says but Fallon also assures
us wary heterosexuals that it's a it's a
very good film on its own merits he says
the good news he says is that the movie
is crude raunchy and sexy because those
are obviously the adjectives that are
going to motivate straight people to see
a gay film and best of all Fallen says
Bros quote jokes about life as a gay
male over the age of 30 over the age of
40 even in New York City in a way that
feels authentic
now part of that authenticity apparently
is a four-way gay sex scene which the
writer promises Rings true
I could just hear some average straight
guy in Ohio one of millions across the
country saying to his wife hey honey
let's go check out this gay romantic
comedy called Bros tonight yeah
apparently it jokes about life as a gay
male over 30 in New York City in a way
that feels authentic yeah Kevin Fallon
The Daily Beast he says so he says that
we should see it so we could be good
allies also uh it's super raunchy and
sexy with all the gay orgies and
everything doesn't that sound great we
can go to Olive Garden afterwards
you can imagine these types of
conversations but you can only imagine
them because they don't happen in real
life Kevin Fallon of The Daily Beast may
or may not understand that but the real
point I think of trying to emotionally
blackmail straight people into seeing a
gay film is so that when we don't
respond the film's failure can be blamed
on you guessed it homophobia well if you
like me are insecure and desperate and
need more approval and more respect then
uh that's why you need established
titles established titles is your
opportunity to earn the title of Lord or
lady and gain the respect that you so
richly deserve or think you do anyway
all you need is a one square foot plot
of land in Scotland in your title pack
you'll be bestowed with at least one
square foot of dedicated land on a
private estate in edelston Scotland plus
an official certificate which is what
I'm holding with a Crest your
certificate features a unique plot
Number with which you can see the exact
location of your land title packs from
established titles are a fun and unique
gift for any occasion and there are even
couple packs that come with an adjoining
plot of land for the special someone in
your life with your certificate you
could officially add the prefix of Lord
or lady to your credit card plane ticket
and even your dating profiles my wife
has been begging me to take her on a
trip to Europe and so maybe I do this
instead I say we're not going to go but
I got you a square foot plot of land in
Scotland you'll never see it but it's
there and get this established titles
told me that the first 200 people
purchasing a title pack using my
exclusive link will receive a plot
within a few walking minutes of mine
that's exciting so depending on how many
of you want to become a lawyer lady we
can build our own kingdom established
titles is actually running a massive
sale right now plus if you use code
Walsh you get an additional 10 off so go
to established titles.com Walsh to get
your gifts now and help support the
channel so the rest of this I don't even
need to tell you because you knew this
was going to happen right on cue the
star of the film Billy Eichner was uh
ready with this excuse he was just right
away Sunday night he was tweeting
tweeting up a storm this is all the
fault of homophobia
so he tweeted uh quote last night I
snuck in and sat in the back of a
sold-out theater playing Bros in Los
Angeles the audience howled with
laughter from start to finish burst into
Applause at the end and some were wiping
away tears as they walked out it was
truly magical yeah sure they did this
has this has very sort of um my
girlfriend goes to a different High
School vibe to it right you know this oh
yeah the audience is they loved it I
mean they were they just I I promise you
I saw one I saw an audience that loved
it I really did
anyway uh he continues really I am very
proud of this movie Rolling Stone
already has Bros on the list of the best
comedies of the 21st century that part I
believe I bet they did do that what's
also true is that at one point a theater
chain called Universal called Universal
and said that they were pulling the
trailer because of the gay content
America F yeah etc etc
that's just the world we live in
unfortunately even with glowing reviews
great Rotten Tomatoes scores an a cinema
score
Etc straight people especially in
certain parts of the country just didn't
show up for Bros and that's
disappointing because but it is what it
is everyone who isn't a homophobic
weirdo should go see Bros tonight you'll
have a blast and it is special and
uniquely powerful to see this particular
story on a big screen especially for
queer folks who don't get this
opportunity often I love this movie so
much go Bros
all right so you're a homophobic weirdo
if you don't spend
too much money and several hours of your
time going out to watch a romantic
comedy about men who meet at a gay bar
and then proceed to have group sex with
other gay men
you are a homophobic you're not just
homophobic you're a weirdo it is weird
that you didn't spend you didn't go you
didn't hire a babysitter and take your
wife out to watch that movie it's
actually it's a weird thing how weird is
that
a pretty Stark pivot in terms of
messaging we must say because the
trailer if you watch it all the way to
the end which I we bailed so you didn't
see at the end but this is in the
trailer the trailer goes out of its way
to insult straight people
uh it says you know straight people are
over they're irrelevant they're stupid
they're terrorists that's in the trailer
they're irrelevant and terrorists that
actually says it in the trailer and then
the movie bombs and suddenly it's hey
why didn't straight people come see this
hey you irrelevant idiot terrorists come
watch our movie dumbasses you owe it to
us
a slightly uh schizophrenic marketing
campaign
but there is an important lesson I think
that we can learn from this whole
Fiasco and there's a reason I'm talking
about it and it's not just to make fun
of this movie for doing so poorly that's
like that's 80 of the reason 20 is
because there's a lesson
so some have speculated that Hollywood
knows that films like this will bomb and
yet they put the film out anyway
and I've seen that a lot on Twitter oh
Hollywood knew that this would happen
because they don't care it's just about
the message
but that's not true okay because
Hollywood is still a business and you
don't make a film and release it on over
3 000 screens and spend 40 million
dollars marketing it if you don't think
it will perform now maybe you put it out
put it in a couple independent theaters
spend no money marketing it and then you
could just say look we made it see we're
woke or whatever maybe you do that but
you don't put the the money and support
behind it if you don't think it's going
to do well and so they did think it
would do well
they really expected it to be a hit
which only goes to show how terminally
out of touch Hollywood has become
I mean because there is in fact this is
the great thing about this
there is no genre of film less likely to
succeed than a gay romantic comedy
you have just combined things in such a
way as it is a perfect storm uh in in
terms of like making a movie that will
bomb it is it's the sort of film
seemingly designed to appeal to the
smallest possible subset of potential
moviegoers
so heterosexual women are
um the normal audience for romantic
comedy
but they want to see a romance they can
relate to or or aspire to right they
want to be able to relate to it or they
want to be able to dream of themselves
in a similar situation
they could do neither of those things
with a story about two men hooking up at
a gay club okay when you got a bunch of
guys meeting each other on Grindr that
is not the sort of romance that women
have in mind
meanwhile straight men
are loathed to see romantic comedies of
any type my wife has convinced me to
watch maybe five total in 10 years of
marriage and it took some it took a
sustained emotional and psychological
pressure campaign to extract even those
concessions out of me
so she gets like she gets like one every
two years okay
so if if we're already reluctant to
watch heterosexual romantic comedies why
would you think you could get us to
watch a gay one
it's a it's a pretty bold strategy so
you're already having trouble selling
something to someone so then you go in
and and make the product less appealing
and expect better results
oh you didn't want to buy this car sir
well here let me have it painted hot
pink and then we'll um see how you feel
about it
kind of tactic that made sense in the
minds of Hollywood producers because
they exist in a solar system 50 million
light years from the planet the rest of
us are living on
which is why their output is so
atrocious
but the good news the real good news is
that as they relegate themselves to
irrelevance Opportunities arise for
other people to tell stories and make
films and create content that actually
connects with the average person
now I didn't mean for this all to lead
to a sales pitch for the daily wire but
that is something we're trying to do
over here such as my film what is a
woman which is better and funnier and
more relevant and more important and far
more successful than Hollywood's
historic gay romantic comedy
and the other piece of the good news is
that um I'm taking the film on the road
touring college campuses across the
country my first stop is tomorrow when
I'll screen the film at Catholic
University in DC
so I hope to see you there
I guess this was all leading to a sales
pitch but what can you do and we'll
leave it there for this course of the
show as we move over into the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]